hi everyone it's Jerry I have a
beautiful and instructive 17 move game
to share with you this was played in
2003 at the under4 world youth
Championship on the white end
13-year-old John ludvig Hammer rated
2074 playing against 12-year-old
International Master Magnus Carlson
rated
2450 let's have a look we have a hyper
modern start to this
one black says go ahead occupy the
center I'll look to chip away at it
later King Bishops contribute kings are
tucked away more pressure on White
Center the reply here
C3 in general black welcomes
D5 not because this Knight can advance
and counter punch that just happens to
be an uh an added bonus bigger pitcher
idea is that this bishop is Happy its
scope has been extended with the pawn
now on
D5 this is a point black will next look
to
challenge in this game it's the simple
solid
C3
E5
coordination on D4 it's adequately
defended white ensures that this Knight
will be around to secure the center
points no worries now of a
pin move eight the start of an
offensive Knight
H5 the halfway point of the
game now in preparing for this video I
made several p passes through this game
my very first pass I saw the ending of
the game and I thought that's beautiful
and then as I played through it a few
more times I started to notice a few
different patterns with within just
these handful
moves I wonder if you can maybe pick up
on what these patterns
are so first of all what is happening
with this last move how might we
describe it black is coordinating with
his
furthest Advanced
Pawn F4 is one square and the other is
D4 D4 is red hot hit three times
defended twice white needs to do
something about
D4 white decides on the capture D takes
E5 there are three ways black can
recapture in this
position what would be your move in this
position feel free to pause the
video okay Carlson's move Knight
F4 no recapture no routine recapture
here Carlson is attentive to a
vulnerable point in White's Camp the
bishop is under Fire also
H3 coordinated pressure
there white goes to B5
the Knight now takes on E5 which makes
this bishop a bit silly now it's sort of
a staring off into space Bishop also
there's coordination on D3 a possible
jump
there computer suggests Knight C4 as a
followup in this game it is Knight takes
Knight there are now two ways black can
recapture what would be your move in
this position feel free to pause the
video okay did I get you again the very
best move no routine recapture
again Queen G5 takes advantage of the
weakness of White's last move what is
going on here Carlson is coordinating
with his furthest Advanced peace the
king Knight there's a mate threat on G2
the G2 Pawn is
pinned Queen F3 to defend on G2 is not
working Knight takes H3 is there
anything more happening yes the queen
x-rays this staring off into space
Bishop white plays in the best way
Knight
G4 Queen takes
Bishop black is still coordinating with
this Knight
we have
E2 and
D3 the suggestion by the engine in this
position the move played in the game
first of all is Knight
B3 the suggestion by the engine is to
flick in
A3 the queen on B5 is a very flexible
piece she does after all
Patrol a fifth rank a completely opened
fifth
rank if a four is
played it suggests giving a check and
then sneaking into
D3 slight Advantage here still for team
black no A4 though in this one Knight
B3 Knight
E2 check King H1 the Knight has cut the
Queen off from defending the Knight
Bishop takes Knight
now on recaptures
and Carlson just goes after a weak link
Pawn on e4 not easy to defend this guy
yet again the computer suggests A4 here
in reply to that Queen goes to C4 that's
what's being recommended A4 is not
played in this game Bishop E3 is on
board before we look at Bishop E3 though
I want to point out some
variations
suppose white defends E4
directly so for instance F3 why is that
not working well there'd be Knight G3
now with the
fork well what about the queen going to
C2 or maybe even D5 to defend
E4 let's put on one of the
moves there's Knight G3 the queen no
longer defends the Knight there's a
trick black will win the
exchange
finally suppose the Knight retreats to
defend this Pawn how can black play
here it says you could go ahead and
simply take the
bishop Queen recaptures to defend the
pawn and it likes playing on the king
side with
H5 and there's even lines here where the
king could go to G7 Rook to h8 and
looking for mate on the H file there's a
lot of pressure
here threat to take the Knight take on
e4 if you play here there's Bishop to E3
black is in a winning
position so no Knight D2 it's just the
simple Bishop
development Rook takes E4
follows if in this position white
creates a flight square with
G3 there's Knight takes G3 with check
Pawn takes and Rook takes Bishop
completely winning for black up two
pawns everything is better here for
black in this game some pressure on the
Knight final Pop
Quiz Can you spot Carlson's 17th move
feel free to pause the
video okay final
move Queen
H5 white
resigns Queen sacrifice for the
win if Pawn captures Queen we would have
Rook
H4
mate
Anastasia's
mate what did you think of this one
there were a few parts of this game that
struck me one note how there were
multiple cases of no routine
recaptures instead a more forceful move
was played two note the attention that
was given to unprotected pieces Carlson
targeting White's King Bishop on
multiple occasions three note how
Carlson found ways to coordinate with
his furthest Advanced Pawn
E5 and peace King Knight when it was on
F4 in even in this final position
E2 and of course the aesthetic ending a
queen sacrifice leading to Anastasia's
mate who doesn't enjoy that maybe
Hammer anyhow Feel Free as usual to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comments section below I hope you
enjoyed it and maybe took a thing or two
away that's all for now take care
bye